oh boy we're going there hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
we will be looking at fellow dietitian
and best body program founder dr rachel
paul of college nutritionist but first
let me tell you what my sponsor bill
barr
snack lovers rejoice if you have yet to
find a protein bar that doesn't taste
like chalk listen to me and listen to me
carefully
guys they taste like a chocolate bar and
a nook at bar had a baby and i'm here
for it i'm ready to throw the baby
shower all right clearly i'm having baby
fever somebody stop me
what flavor are we going for today
obviously i feel like i need a little
chunk of something in my mouth
[Music]
and preferably chocolate
let's dive in
coconut brownie
chunk what's not to love
can you tell i've had a lot of coffee
today
yes ma'am oh there's big chunks
all on top
oh yeah
baby jams baby dance
she good and 15 grams of protein hello
so these bad boys are great for like a
light snack on their own or i love to
pair them with some fruit oats yogurt or
like a smoothie for more substantial
hunger crushing combo snack so if you
want to trail build by yourself check
out the link in my description and use
my promo code abbiesharp15 to get 15 off
of your order and don't forget to pause
the screen or look at my description for
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning as we will be discussing
restrictive dieting also a reminder that
this is not a critique of rachel
personally but i will be sharing my
perspective on her program and posts to
help you determine if it's the right
content for you and if you're new here
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel ring that bell and follow me
over on instagram and tick tock at
abby's kitchen okay so
i don't think i get requests for any
other content creator quite as much as i
do rachel i received loki thousands of
dms about the college nutritionist
instagram content and her best body
program and as always i'm going to
approach this with respect and the
acknowledgement that different coaching
approaches are going to work for
different people but you guys are all
here because you relate to my approach
so i paid to sign myself up for her
program to check it out before you do
now before we get into this paid program
i want to chat briefly about rachel's
approach from what i can see online
first of all what i agree with and like
now there is no doubt in my mind that
rachel is an intelligent woman and
considering her own weight loss success
story
i can appreciate her appeal for one i
really like when she mentions the
satisfaction factor which is something
that you guys all know i talk about all
the time take a look
eating foods that are the most
satisfying to you is actually one of the
best ways to lose weight and then
maintain that lost weight let's do an
example dark chocolate has more health
benefits than milk chocolate right it
has more antioxidants more fiber however
for me personally milk chocolate is just
more satisfying i like the taste better
and i am more satisfied on a smaller
amount so think about where can you
apply this seven yes yes yes
i am also a milk chocolate girl myself
and we know that when you just eat for
nutrition or for calorie restriction you
set yourself up for a binge you need to
enjoy the foods you're eating or you're
just gonna go on a satisfaction hunt
trying to find what you actually want
plowing through a lot more unsatisfying
calories in the process you want to talk
about empty calories real empty calories
are the ones you don't like i also think
there are some really helpful tools here
for recognizing hunger and fullness and
i agree with her sentiment that feeling
some hunger is normal and even healthy
to experience because that's our natural
motivator for intuitive eating as with
most dietitians on social media you also
see you're recommending a more gentle
approach to overeating that really
embodies what i would also suggest which
is if you overeat do not punish yourself
use it as data and move on by eating
normally rather than trying to
compensate with like punishing exercise
or more restriction and finally i think
the general tips she shares online for
weight loss are all evidence-based and
also relatively gentle at heart her
approach is to focus on meals and foods
that you legitimately like to not create
a massive caloric deficit that would
trigger a binge and to lean on
convenience foods to help create more
realistic and sustainable habits and i
also think she's grown a lot in her mo
my team dug deep
into her ig feed and we found her
popular example meal plans from 2017
were all in the 1300 to 1400 calories a
day mark and i even found one with 1200
calories which in my professional
opinion is insanely low to recommend to
the masses her more recent posts don't
list calories which i like or when they
do they're in the 1700 to 2000 calorie
range which i think feels a lot more
reasonable for weight loss to me i don't
think we need any more nutrition
propaganda promoting the 1200 calorie
diet how about new as for rachel's
general diet format i analyzed a handful
of her example days for filling meals
and snacks and i found that they usually
follow a kind of standard formula i see
lots of evidence of the hunger crushing
combo going on so fiber rich carbs
protein and healthy fats and her recipes
seem relatively approachable nutrient
dense and still pretty fun there's
definitely a focus on volume rich meals
which some research suggests volume can
have a positive impact on perceived
satiety while other research has found
that its impact is actually quite
limited ultimately my take on volume
eating is that if it encourages folks to
eat more fiber rich fruits and veg
that's great i love that but it is also
hard to convince your body that water or
air is equivalent to food so at the end
of the day calories are going to be more
satiating than volume what i will also
say is that where i think some
influencers could take this whole volume
eating into kind of orthorexic extremes
rachel's suggested portion sizes seem
satisfying yet not abnormal or
disorderly if that makes sense which is
nice to see in this space but the way
her suggested plans usually look on
instagram are breakfast is almost always
straight up fat and protein and rarely
any carbs going on so it's usually egg
and avocado-based lunch is usually a
huge salad with protein usually also
very low carb but occasionally there's
like a little bit of fruit in there or
in a rare instance maybe a tiny serving
of grains so in her program she calls
this the hashtag that formula for lunch
and dinner where she recommends two cups
of veggies four to five ounces of lean
protein and one to two ounces of added
fat and i get that this maybe works for
rachel but it doesn't seem ideal for
folks who maybe exercise in the morning
or who feel their best having their
carbs earlier on in the day in fact some
research on circadian rhythms suggests
that your body is actually better at
burning carbs in the morning and fat in
the evening so there may be a metabolic
benefit to kind of front loading those
calories and carbs earlier on in the day
but anyways moving on snack is usually
also again protein or fat based
with an occasional piece of fruit thrown
in the mix dinner is very similar to
lunch except the veggies are usually
cooked so again we've got like a low
carb high volume protein and veggie
based meal and then finally dessert is
usually like a small portion of some
kind of fun food whether that's a piece
of candy ice cream cookies chocolate etc
now
trigger warning for edie mention here
but i do have to say that when i was
struggling with disordered eating this
was not unlike how i wanted to eat like
i would set it up so i ate super clean
high volume low carb meals all day and
with my kind of perfectionist type a
delayed gratification approach to life i
would have the one food that i really
wanted before bed so my concern is that
for folks who have struggled with
dieting their whole lives that this way
of eating may set them up for an evening
binge when their willpower and their
energy levels are naturally at their
lowest and again this will work for some
people and when prompted in one post
rachel notes that she just prefers not
to eat starchy carbs or fruit she
prefers to eat her carbs as dessert and
personal preferences like this are
totally fine totally works at the end of
the day the most successful diet is the
one where you can maintain a caloric
deficit and still be happy happy happy
happy happy happy so if having dessert
at bedtime over having rice at lunch
makes you happy then that's what's going
to work again calorie deficit is going
to override any circadian rhythm
benefits that we briefly discussed but
this isn't just sharing what i like this
is sharing professional suggestions for
the masses and she specifically says
that she airs on the low carb side
because she thinks that the research for
weight loss is strongest for low carb i
disagree a meta-analysis of 48 studies
found that low carb and low fat yielded
similar weight loss results it
ultimately is going to come down to what
is most enjoyable to you and this may be
what's most enjoyable for rachel it
sounds like it is but when the lion's
share of the meals a professional
recommends to the masses features this
personal preference i do worry about it
demonizing grains or fruits in people's
minds i also worry that most people who
wait all day for carbs are just not
going to be able to succeed at limiting
themselves to just like a half cup of
ice cream before bed this is definitely
a risk for a binge also just looking at
the pictorial representation of these
days which i know limits accuracy but
i'm counting maybe 1400 to 1500 calories
tops and around 100 grams of carbs which
again is likely not enough for a lot of
women so bottom line here if low carb
does not bring you joy this might not be
the plan for you now my biggest concern
however are the three little words that
appear in her profile permanent weight
loss some rd's would be like really
angry about this and call it like
malpractice or something like that i'm
just gonna call it like false
advertising and chalk it up to an appeal
to sensationalism and listen i get
better than anyone that it is very hard
to compete with the [ __ ]
pseudoscience woo out there when like
influencers are promising that you can
lose 10 pounds in 10 days just by
drinking some kind of shake frozen
dessert
but the body of research suggests that
at least 80 percent of people who lose a
significant amount of weight will not
maintain that after a year and dieters
regain more than half of what they lose
within two years even if her approach is
more sustainable than like a juice
cleanse this is still a diet and bodies
that diet are still subject to
compensatory mechanisms that make
permanent weight loss quite difficult
not impossible of course but difficult
and to be fair rachel's profile doesn't
reflect that difficulty by saying
permanent weight loss for 20 of people
and i get it that's that's not a great
sound bite but there are power in words
and i just do not agree with those words
not today's thing but let's switch gears
here to talk about her best body program
which her website suggests will help you
feel more in control of food and
permanently lose 5 to 50 pounds again
don't love that joining the program
costs 37 a month or 266 dollars if you
join for the year so
is this worth your
cash well first of all i think where
rachel really shines is in her behavior
psychology expertise her program has
modules that encourage you to visualize
your future self and to determine ways
to add joy to your life other than
through food she specifically says don't
let food be your only pleasure in the
day and i think that this mentality is
critical for everyone but especially for
people who are dieting i also like that
she encourages tracking when you eat
foods that do not satisfy you but to
move on from that experience and to not
shame yourself or dwell this is not
unlike my tip of using eating
experiences as data to really help to
inform future meals without letting
guilt trigger a restrict binge cycle her
plan also feels relatively gentle which
i think sets you up for the best chance
for long term success as she suggests a
more modest half a pound weekly weight
loss goal or a 250 calorie deficit per
day i am not saying that this is an easy
feat for anyone but i do think it's
certainly more realistic than most
weight loss programs that i review in
her section on weight maintenance she
offers some more insights that i think
could be helpful she states that at this
point you can stop tracking and pivot to
listening to your body's cues and to
basically just adjust your goal to
happiness over a specific number above
all else knowing that at the end of the
day genetics are going to play a role
here she also believes that weight
regain is often a self-fulfilling
prophecy because we believe we're
incapable of maintaining our weight loss
over time and while i'm not sure i
believe that to be the cause of weight
regain since we have ample evidence on
the biological compensatory mechanisms
that derail long-term weight loss
maintenance i do think that this is a
hearty attempt to help people feel
somewhat in control and empowered in
their journey and i do think it's
important to have a positive mindset for
any difficult task weight loss included
the only concern with this approach is
that when or if folks do regain weight
despite utilizing all the suggested
affirmations and other strategies in the
course that they will feel like it's
their fault and from reading rachel's
content and hearing her voice a lot i
get the sense that she's an empathetic
practitioner who would agree with me
that it is not the individual's fault as
for what i don't love you guys know i
don't like tracking calories and rachel
does recommend being as accurate as
possible with busting out like the
measuring cups and the spoons and the
food scales i understand this data is
helpful for a lot of folks but i also
think it can be overwhelming at best and
triggering at worst so i personally
think that there are gentler approaches
that would yield a similar calorie
deficit without consuming so much energy
and mental real estate each day the
other thing i think is slightly
confusing is that the base meal plans
clock in at under or around 1200
calories now the video instructions
teach you how to adjust your daily
calories and then add in meals increase
portion sizes or add ingredients like
cheese or sauces to hit your calorie
goal and i gotta throw this girl a bone
i mean she built an amazing program and
meal database that helps you build up
your meals if you follow these
instructions as she suggests you do but
considering there is a very important
disclaimer here to not follow a meal
plan with less than 1200 calories
without direct medical supervision i'm
not quite sure why the suggested meal
plans even start so low like i love the
customization here but i can think of
very few non-medicalized scenarios where
a healthy adult would only need 1200
calories but it's not enough and because
1200 calories has been printed so hard
in diet culture vernacular as the
calorie level for weight loss i worry
that this base just reinforces that very
dangerously false suggestion i think her
rationale for doing this is to allow
more flexibility but professionally
speaking i would be worried about the
assumptions that people will make with
that base meal plan since so many folks
out there will always think less is more
and a greater deficit is inherently
better i don't think that's right it
ain't supposed to be like that so to
wrap this up generally speaking i think
rachel is a very smart practitioner with
both professional and personal
experience with weight loss and i do
think that this knowledge shows her
program seems to be kind of what noon
promises is but fails that being it is
incredibly detailed and well put
together and if i'm being honest now
that i'm signed up i can totally see
myself using it as kind of meal
inspiration when i'm feeling in a rut
but honestly let's be real i will
totally forget to unsubscribe that's how
they get you that's how they get you
gotcha i also think that while a lot of
her free content or plants on instagram
seem more geared toward the formula that
works for her which may not be ideal for
a lot of people it does feel inspiring
appetizing and approachable if that
style works for you too this is probably
not content for you if you find going
low carb triggers a binge because most
of the meals and snacks that she
recommends are lower carb and it's
definitely not the content for you if
tracking everything is emotionally
consuming and i also warn that it is
imperative that for this to even
possibly result in permanent weight loss
it has to be done at a modest
sustainable pace and that means 1200
calories is not
enough and you absolutely will need to
add meals and calories to this plan so
do not fall into the common pitfall that
less is more but in the grand scheme of
weight loss plans i think rachel's
suggestions feel relatively gentle
evidence-based psychology informed and
help you get into a supportive mindset
for behavior change and when we're
dealing with something like long-term
weight loss all of those little details
are a lot more important than just what
you're eating and on that note that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who or what you want to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]